can you speak to the unique elements of
the various schools of that soviet
marxism so we got leninism
trotskyism stalinism maybe even let's
expand out to uh maoism so um maybe i
could speak to sort of leninism
uh and then please tell me if i'm saying
dumb things
there's a
i think for lenin there was an idea that
there could be a small
sort of vanguard party like a small
controlling entity that's like wise and
is able to do the central planning
decisions
then for um
stalinism one interesting so stalin's
implementation of all of this one
interesting characteristic is to
move away from the international aspect
of the ideal marxism to
uh make it all about nation nationalism
the strength of nation
and then um so maoism is
it's it's different in that it's focused
on uh agriculture and rural
um and then trotskyism i don't know
except that it's anti-stalin
i mean i don't even know if there's
unique sort of philosophical elements
there anyway can you maybe from those or
something else speak to different unique
elements that are interesting to think
about about implementation of marxism in
the real world probably the best way to
get in there into this
is to describe something that happened
in
marxism that then shapes the answer to
your question
in the early days of marx's writings
yeah and you know he his life spans the
19th centuries born in 1818 dies in 1883
so literally he lives the 19th century
and
you might i mean to make things simple
you might look at the first half of the
first two-thirds of his life
as overwhelmingly
gathering together
the precursors to his own work marx was
unusually
scholarly in the sense that partly
because he didn't work a regular job and
partly because he was an exile in london
most of his adult life
he worked in the library i mean he had a
lot of time he got subsidized a little
bit by angles whose family were
manufacturers
and
you might say the first half to
two-thirds of his life are about
the critique of capitalism
and that was what
in a broad sense the audience for his
work
western europe more or less
uh was interested in that's what they
wanted
and he gave that to them he wasn't the
only one but he was very very effective
at it
um
by the last third of his life
he and the other
producers of a anti-capitalist movement
people like the chartists in england
that's a whole nother movement
um
the
anarchists of various kinds like prudent
in france or krapotkin or bakunin in
russia and so on
uh you put all these together and there
was a shift
in what the audience
let's call it a mixture of
militant working class people on the one
hand
and critical or radical intelligence on
the other
they now wanted a different question
they were persuaded by the analysis they
were agreeable that capitalism
was uh a phase they would like to do
better than
and the question became how do we do
this
not anymore should we why should we
could we maybe fix capitalism no they
had gotten to the point the system has
to be fundamentally changed
but they got they didn't go yet you
might imagine they didn't go and say
well what will that new system looks
like
they didn't go that way what they did
was ask the question
how
could we get beyond capitalism it seems
so powerful it seems to have captured
people's minds people's daily lives and
so on
um and the
focus of the conversation became this
was already by the last third of the
19th century
the question of
the agency the mechanism whereby we
would get beyond and again make a long
story short
the conversation focused
on seizing the government
see before that it wasn't that the
government was not a major interest if
you read
marx's capital the great work of his
maturity three volumes there's almost
nothing in the state i mean he mentions
it but
he's interested in the details of how
capitalism works
factory by factory store by store office
what's the structure the government's
secondary for him but there's also
humans within that capitalist system of
there's the working class right it's
about that's what he's struggle that's
what he's he's interested in each in the
world think of it almost mechanically
like the workplace in the workplace
there some people who do this and other
people who do that and they accept this
division of authority and they accept
this division of what's going on here
particularly because he believed that
the core economic objective of
capitalism was to maximize something
called profit which his analysis located
right there in the
workings of the enterprise
not in the government was not the the
key factor here and he was looking at
ideas of value
yes how much is the
how much value does the labor of the
individual workers provide and that
means
how do we reward the workers in an
ethical way and so those are the
questions of uh well
we'll get yeah okay but the government
is not part of that picture okay so it's
very significant that towards the end of
the 19th century marx is still alive
when this begins but it it really gets
going after he dies
is this debate among marxists
about the role of the state
they all agree nearly all of them agree
that you have to get the same the
working class has to get the state
because they see the state as the
ultimate guarantor of capitalism when
things get really out of hand the
capitalist calls the police or he calls
the army or both of them and so the
government is in a sense this key
institution
captured in marx's lang marxist language
by the bourgeoisie by the by the other
side the capitalists
and yet vulnerable because of suffrage
if suffrage is universal or nearly so
if everybody gets a vote
which in a way capitalism brings to bear
part of its rejection of feudalism in
the french american revolution is to
create a place where elected represented
so that the government being
subject to suffrage
creates the notion aha
here's how we're gonna we have to seize
this state
and then th
that gets agreed upon but there's a big
split as to how to do it
one side says
you go with the election you you
mobilize the voter
that gets to be called reformism within
marxism and the other side is revolution
don't do that this system if i may quote
bernie again is rigged
uh you can't get there
they've long ago learned how to
manipulate uh parliaments
they buy the politicians and all that
and therefore revolution is going to be
the way to do it revolution
gets a very big boost because the
russians they did it that way they
didn't do i mean they fought in the
douma in the in the parliament but they
didn't and that this focus on the state
i would argue
goes way beyond what the debaters at the
time
uh and if you're interested in the great
names
there was a great theorist of the
the role of the state in a reformist
strategy to get power uh in germany
named edward bernstein very important
his opponents in germany
were karl kautzke and rosa luxemburg the
two other huge figures in marxism at the
time and
they wrote the articles that everybody
reads but it was a much broader uh
debate and by the way that debate still
goes on reformism versus revolution
and in in terms not all that different i
mean it's adjusted to history but in
terms of different can you comment uh on
where you
lean in terms of
the mechanism of progress
reformation versus i'd rather tell you
the historical sure
over and over and over again in most
cases
the reformists have always won
because revolution is frightening is
scary is dangerous
um
and so most of the time when you get to
the point where it's even a relevant
discussion not an abstract thing for
conferences but a real
strategic issue
the reform reformists have won i mean
and
i'll give you an example from the united
states in the great depression of the
1930s
you had an extraordinary shift to the
left in the united states the greatest
shift to the left in the country's
history before or since nothing like it
suddenly
you created a vast
left wing
composed of the labor movement
which went crazy in the 19th hour we
organized more people into unions in the
1930s than at any time before or anytime
since it is the explosion and at the
same time the explosion of two socialist
parties and the communist party that
became very powerful and they all worked
together creating
a very powerful leftist
presence in this country
they debated in a strategically real way
reform or revolution
the reformers were the union people by
at large and the the communists were the
revolutionaries by and large because
they were affiliated with the communist
international with russia and all of
that and in between you might say that
the two socialist parties one that was
trotskyist and inspiration and the other
one more
moderate western european kind of
socialism and they had this intense
debate
and they ended up the reformists won
that debate there was no revolution in
the 1930s here
uh but there was
a reform
that achieved unspeakably great
successes
which is why it was as strong and
remains as strong as it does because it
achieved in in a few years in the 1930s
starting around 1932-3
social security in this country we had
never had that before that's the same
one we have now
unemployment insurance never existed
before that you have until today
minimum wage for the first time still
have that today
and a federal program of employment that
hired 15 million people
i mean these were unspeakable gifts if
you like to the working class so that's
the 30s and the 40s 30s very much in the
40s anymore but in the 30s and here's
the best part
it was paid for by taxes on corporations
and the rich
so when people today say well you can
tax the government the joke is i have to
teach american history to americans
uh because it has been erased from
consciousness we'll return to that but
first let's let's take a stroll back to
the beginning of the 20th century with
the russians with the russians so
their interpretation goes like this
everybody was right the state is crucial
we were right we were the
revolutionaries we seized the state here
in russia
now we have the state and socialism
is when the working class captures this
state either by reform a revolution and
then uses its power over the state to
make the transition from capitalism to
the better thing we're going toward
again make a long story short in the
interest of time what happens which is
not unusual in human history
is that the means
becomes the end in other words lenin
who's crystal clear before he you know
he doesn't live very long he dies in 23
so he's only in power from 17 you say to
22 but that time he has his brain
trouble and 1923 by the way not at age
23 yeah yeah before
1923. yeah he's only there for four or
five years
uh he's very clear he even says and i've
done work on i've published so i know
this stuff
he says in a famous speech let's not
fool ourselves
we have captured the state
but we don't have socialism we have to
create that we have to move
towards that
um
with stalin you know lenin dies and
there's a fight between stalin and
trotsky trotsky loses the fight he's
exiled he goes to mexico stalin is now
alone in power and does all the things
he's famous or infamous for
um
and by the end of the 20s stalin
makes
a decision i mean not him they thought
that he makes it alone but
things have evolved in russia so that
they do the following they declare
that they are
socialism in other words socialism
becomes
when you capture the state
not when the state capture has enabled
you to do x y z other things no no the
state itself
once you have it
is socialism so when a socialist
captures the state that's socialism
exactly
and hat that's exactly right
and they feel like that's definitionally
confusing well it shouldn't be because
here we get an example yeah
if you go to many parts of the united
states today and you ask people
what's socialism
they'll tell you they look you right in
the face and they'll say the post office
you you know when i first heard this as
a young man you know what
the post office
it took me a while to understand the
post office amtrak the tennessee
all the examples in the united states
where the government
runs something
this is
socialism
see capitalism is if the government
doesn't run it if a private individual
who's not a government official runs it
well then it's capitalism if the
government takes it then it's socialist
so what is wrong with that
reasoning so the idea i think
there's nothing wrong with it's a way of
looking at the world it's just got
nothing to do with marx well there's
marks there's marxism
let's try to pull this apart so
what role
uh
does central planning have
in marxism
so
marxism is concerned
with this class struggle
with respecting the working class right
what is the connection
between that struggle and central
planning that is often
central planning is often associated
with marxism right so a centralized
power doing russia did that allocation
so that's a that's that has to do with a
very specific set of implementations
initiated by the soviet union has
nothing to do with marx how else can you
do i don't think you can find yes
anywhere in marx's writing anything
about central planning or any other kind
of planning again fundamentally then uh
marx
marx's work it has to do
with um
with factories with workers with with
the bourgeoisie
and and the the exploitation of the
working class
you